cette nuit c'est la pleine lune mais
pourquoi nous présente tel toujours la
même face c'est parce que la lune tourne
sur elle même un tour complet en un peu
plus de 27 jours en même temps qu'elle
fait le tour de la terre si la lune
rester fixé sur son âge quand elle se
retrouve dans cette position on verrait
sa face à et quand elle se trouve dans
cette position
sa face b revenons à la case départ
étant donné que la lune tourne sur elle
même au fur et à mesure qu'elle fait le
tour de la terre sont elle a fait
l'écart du tour de notre planète
elle a également fait un quart de tour
sur elle-même et présente la même face
au point de départ un quart de tour
supplémentaire et elle a encore tourner
sur elle-même et présente toujours la
même face et ainsi de suite
la lune présente toujours la même face
et ne montre jamais sa face cachée même
à bord d'une capsule de déconfit n'est
allé à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain